It's now 9:51... (Even though it's in military time.. but ok)
Okay.
I see the bomb, I'm in- I'm in the basement.
It's ticking down.
Alright.
Alright, we have loominati sign symbols.
Ai.
Do ya wanna start with those?
Let's do it.
Okay, we have ONE, that looks like
a pive- oh shit, i dunno how to sa-
a P backwards, dat spilled in a lil' black in it.
Okai...
Okai x2 Press the aaaaah
You said there was the one like.. a six?
Pewds: Can i trust you cry? >[|]O
Cry: YES
Pewds: This is- this is REAL this time
Cry:THIS IS REAL!!1!
Cry: Press dat 6!!1!
Pewds: It got green, awwh thank GOD
Cry: Press that P
Pewds: I'm pressin' da P
Cry: Now press the K
Pewds: Im pressin' that K-
Cry: Now press the question mark!
Pewds: We did it! x2 (:D)
Pewds: Number One: Yellow, Number Two: Blue
Cry: Ok hold on... uuuhhmmm.. fuuc- OK, alright, hold on hold on
Pewds: Cry, if I die here... (W1t m9?)
Cry: Yes?
Pewds: I want you to take care of Marzia for meh.. (Wow)
Cry: Uhh.. Not gonna happen (bitch..)
*Continous Sound of heartbeat? i dunno fuck it*
Cry: Dont worry 'bout it, we have a- we have a bomb to defuse right now (bitch..)
Cry: OK, so..( w1t m9?)
Pewds: IM WAITING FOR YOUR INSTRUCTIONS( damn, chill son)
Cry: *Unitelligable*
Pewds: You're taking- WHY IS- WHAT are YOU KOOKIN' AT?!! (Probably you in a bikini.. lookin' smexy >:))
Cry: CUT THE SECOND WIRE!!1! THE SECOND WIRE
Pewds: The second wire Cry? (Yes, dont be a dumbass mehn)
Cry: Yes..
Pewds: *Unintelligable* from the top down?
Cry: Just cut the second wire
Pewds: *silently* GAHH..
Pewds: I forgot my pliers (DAMN IT(╯°□°）╯︵ ┻━┻)
Cry: FUCK (╯°□°）╯︵ ┻━┻
Pewds: I'll just tear it (THAT BETTER WORK BITCH OR IM GONNA FLIP ANOTHER FUCKING TABLE)
Cry: Tear it!!
Pewds:IT WORKED!! (Thanks God..)
Cry: YAS Okay
Cry: Next up!
*EENG*
Cry: Sorry..
Pewds:NO IT DIDNT WORK IT DIDNT WORK IT DIDNT WORK
Cry: WHAT DIDNT WORK?
Pewds: OH GAHD OH GAHD OH GAHD OH GAHD >:[] (╯°□°）╯︵ ┻━┻
Cry: CUT THE SECOND WIRE!!
Pewds WAITI- UH I- UH (FUCKING SPEAK ENGLISH)
Pewds: I did it, BUTT there's something missing -there's something missing
Cry: There's something missing?!
Pewds: Uhh.. There's a- There's.. I got serial number..
Cry: Cut the first wire!
Pewds: The first wire..
*EENG*
Cry: Yes.. (TOO LATE BITCH)
Pewds: OH GAHD WE GOT ANOTHER STRIKE CRY!!
Cry: FAK!!1!
Pewds: UEUHEUEA
Pewds: WUUH (STOP CRYING YOU LITTLE BITCH)
Cry: ORAYT, ORAYT UMM..
Cry: Wait, oh shit, i was reading the wrong one.. oooh no (╯°□°）╯︵ ┻━┻
Cry: uhmm.. SOOO (HURRY UP, BITCH IS CRYING AND GONNA EXPLODE!!)
Cry: AH Fuck..
Pewds: AH- WE CANT. MAKE. ANYMORE. MISTAKES.
Cry: Cut... the.. *Music Intensify*
Cry: Alright.. you said there was a red wire?? (FUCKING... GAAAAH (╯°□°）╯︵ ┻━┻)
(╯°□°）╯︵ ┻━┻
Pewds: No..
*Uh-oh*
*Explosion*
(╯°□°）╯︵ ┻━┻[OUTRO](╯°□°）╯︵ ┻━┻
FUCK THIS, IM OUT.. PEYS!!